mosa Pentimento pair non-functional a
Novell Commission reservoir preemie
function
camisa allen prue a Ottawa socio an
affair you represent deceased a a so
Danny Kinsella president Fernandez
maquette a and Jose
Travis come la xpick administration and
a co2 to invert a dot m k fo effective
mo law of social a kevo effective massey
determine le political is any avenue
Mercia la presidents fernandez por la
voy a comprar pono said presidency ocean
obeys oh silly discussion canoes Alvaro
de uros audrey news a lump us fever of
agave ohnkoji yeeeeee
location effective mod de Borda cut a
lemon East civil a difference oj l ro
expose a program la commission nuevo
programa key ready ready market risk la
première POC news alone present a Papa's
a doll is manag near say quadrupole
masala minimum Opia jean preview
danke J levonne is a vendetta jankoji at
el Poco paprikash DiMaggio a wooden mark
po discrete avec la Granja de noir a van
wadi avec la lluvia namaz with hua Zhu
Li differences pay the car illegal
parcel a minimum Opia set in Missoula
portent say to see in Mizuki
necessity in large consultation Pisgah a
party of the cattles ranvier news on
Papa's a
la première la première proposición give
I assume is opening so co-leaders my
soul acacia wood radium OC La Perla de
la Sol khludova socio rocket on Julie
don't to kiss after wash on counterfeit
per likkle administer on fa on Abu Casas
de Sol Amazon of the shock date was so
co-ed honk la la cabeza
mamama particle a a la misión the
prepare a and production povel amazon of
the chakra dead wa socio a news alone
profited satiny the danke see the
consultation Travis actually a Victrola
Zeta mom you see avec la paloma appear
avec la committee economy GSoC Olivet
row committed a ratio museum ex-partner
so cos off to evict a partner so co+ MA
prepare a soup redaction silver los solo
secluded dead WA socio laka leg Elena de
Lydia AIT present
a premiere party so conce a mod Ahmad a
gal mod diamo silver toka politic the
deagle it a non-discrimination quieto
Carmen de la politique
does a commission from permitted the
pass along ley a developer team soccer
school la camisa de le avenue de ba da
samata
the council this morning discussed
future priorities in our work towards
gender equality gender equality is a
human right it also makes economic sense
with a general employment gap of 370
billion
a year we have to remedy this our
upcoming gender equality strategy will
pair specific initiatives to tackle
gender inequality in all its forms with
gender mainstreaming of EU policies and
gender budgeting Jenner equality is not
only an essential human right it's also
smart business yet there is still a
significant gender imbalance when it
comes to decision making in the EU our
women on boards proposal is designed to
help fix this by forcing the issue of
gender balance on corporate boards
whilst leaving member states the
flexibility to keep and apply their own
measures at the same time discrimination
remains widespread in the EU whether
based on sex race or ethnicity religion
or belief age or sexual orientation
for example 59% of Europeans believe
there is widespread discrimination in
their country on the grounds of ethnic
origin or skin colour
53% say the same with regards to sexual
orientation I welcome the efforts of the
Finnish presidency to revive the debate
on non discrimination including
negotiations on the equal treatment
directive while many member states
support the proposal there is still no
unanimity perhaps this is an issue which
we have to discuss one day also we must
now knuckle down and make Swift progress
on both these directives the Commission
is happy to help in any way it can it
can to achieve further progress I want
also to say a word on the European
semester we had a very fruitful
discussion during lunch on reforming
revamping and also simplifying the
European semester this is an essential
part of economic and social government
governance in the European Union
this commission wants to add to this
European semester also the as DG's which
is a very important aspect of the Green
Deal but at the same time we have to
watch that we are not overload the boat
so how can we streamline the European
semester to encourage ownership of the
European semester to have a better
exchange with member states but also
with the European Parliament and social
partners I think this is a very
important element if we want to achieve
the reforms the Commission is proposing
especially in the framework of the
country
specific recommendations on health and
safety at work I have listened very
carefully to what the presidency has
said and especially to the to the
council conclusions for me as the former
Labor Minister this is a key issue and
really we have to continue working on it
because we have thousands of people
dying at work in Europe and this is not
acceptable so we have really to to to
engage ourselves to commit ourselves to
reduce not only professional diseases
and but also especially the number of
fatal accidents at workplaces and
therefore the idea of a zero vision
which exists already in some Member
States has also to be promoted at the
European level and you have mentioned a
certain number of MU in a way new
diseases which are very much linked also
to the changes in our economy linked to
a new technologies these are issues
which we have to really deal with and
though therefore I have received a
message from the Member States that once
the present strategic framework is
expiring we have to work on a new one
unfortunately husband safety is not an
issue which finishes with the strategic
framework so we have to renew this
framework enrich it and adapt it to the
new challenges well I think you you have
said a lot on the vulnerable people on
the labour market it's true that the
labor the labor market in the European
Union has improved a lot we have the
highest level of employment even
compared to before the crisis but but we
have to acknowledge that there are
groups of people who still are not taken
taking advantage of these improvements
these are very often people with
disability these are young people
without any precise skills these are
women these are more aged people and
unskilled people so we have really to
focus our employment policies to these
categories because in a situation where
labor markets very often need people
there's a paradox that on one hand there
are a lot of vacancies on our labor
markets and on the other hand we have
still people who cannot find a job who
cannot enter the labor market so we have
to make our labor markets more inclusive
that means we have to invest in those
who are not ready to enter the labor
market and I think in all our
discussions we had one important topic
and that's skills skills skills I think
this is an essential element of good
employment policies this is an essential
element to make our labour market more
inclusive but also to favor professional
mobility on our labour market because
people expect
the possibility if their job is changing
if their job disappears that they can
find rapidly a new job and in times of
big transitions Greendale but also
digitalization we have to give people
the tool to take advantage out of this
professional mobility and not get the
feeling that they are left behind that
they are the losers of this evolutions
and these changes and therefore the
Commission we come up very soon with a
revised skills agenda and I look forward
to work with the Croatian presidency on
this topic because they have they
consider that this topic is one of their
priorities so I think for the time being
that's that's already enough thank you
thank you very much commissioner the
floor is now open for questions please
state your name and the media you
represent who'd like to begin I think
there's a question over here
please go ahead we
[Music]